إلى الثنائي الحب لذلك حيث القانون
يجعل tebbane france يضحك في 4 la viburnum
موطن لأنه الكوبرا الجدران و
سيلينا برانا حبيبي دينافيت
دعونا نربط مذكرتها aa2 evening anelka ni
كان هذا هو الحال تحت حصى الكوا
وربط الحجم والرسوم
يجب بطريقة
المجاهدين في لا أكسل ارتفع الحظر الذي تخلقه
طبيعيا zamina mina الحياة و
القواعد في mounabbeh the zumba في
كولومبيا
المستنقع الجديد يانكيز هذه الوكالة و
هناك
yuma بنطلون جينز أريزونا من
طن ريغا واشنطن أين نحن
لكل متبرع مثل عبارة تبغ
فشل في تتبع ملف jo js bach أو
الثعلب الكسندرا
[موسيقى]
مارك كنت أو بعد ارتفاع أسعار الدجاج
مع أربع مراوح أو اليوم تراكم
هذه المساعدات camatte من طفولتي إلى
باتا عراره عمان مثل حكم في يوم
المتفرجين ينظرون على مضض جدا تا
البامور سقوط هو إذا كانت لنا خارقة أو
أقل دراماتيكية فورد ميلز المحامي السابق
لا لها
ضع علامة free the latte at 12:21 p.m. في سكرة
العلاقة بالآخرين
الأشخاص الذين رأيتهم يتطورون في
أبرشية
بعض الذين ليسوا متأكدين منهم
لم يجرؤ على لمسه أن يكون
مقدس ما قبل أن يكون كاهنا
من هو لا يقصد في النهاية
عندما يكونون في الغالب من النساء و
الرجال وعلامات من قبل
أن أكون أمام الكهنة أنا
عانى لفترة طويلة ليتم وضعها
في وضع
[موسيقى]
وبصرف النظر عن الآخرين ما هو لدينا
كانت العلاقة بسيطة للغاية
lancelot شبكة من
الأسعار عند علامة الرنة سيئة
يحب الرياضيون الخامات
مزارع محار جبل Péko مثله
روما أو 200 م
كانت لدي صورة القروض المكسورة
ما نهاية وتريد رمي و
خاطئ لا يخالف القانون
لكنها مميزة عندما يكون هناك شيء ما
غريب في الواقع في البداية لدي
تم أخذها بشكل سيء للغاية في الواقع تم اتخاذها بشكل سيء للغاية
حاليا أنا أعتبر نفسي
حقا مثل تعليق في الواقع
إنه حقًا خطأ
[موسيقى]
boutadjin canafe الرئيس أو أن يحسب
الكانيس في الجير روك أند رول منفردا
cia cia kenneth la roja خلال الخرزة
royat النبيذ دمارت الرياضة في كايين بها
ذكي وهو كيف يبدو
مسافة يقظة الانتباه
الحذر حتى هنا هي الشروط
التي يتم استخدامها ثم اكتشفت
هذا بالإضافة إلى الشباب الذين لا يستطيعون
نفترض تماما
ميولهم الجنسية المثلية
جسديًا جدًا ولكن في بعض الساعات
الكنيسة التي أراه في الحوزة
لذلك بدأ هذا يثير قلقي ولكن
ما زلت في ذلك بالنسبة لها لي
لا أعرف ما إذا كان يعطيني ويعطيني
إعطائي
وكامل وكامل
لذلك أضع ذلك جانباً وأسرع في بلدي
كنم مع سعيد الاحسان في
وقت الغارة المادية cairn india pti
بيمز كما حرفي 10 جيجابايت من ذاكرة الوصول العشوائي
سوف تتشبث الرجال الرقائقي و
موس ثامر يكرر الليبرالي الأبدي
شرائح أو ساخنة على رجيم وبرجها
هنري نالت يا الكنيسة الكاثوليكية
للأسف اليوم يقدم أ
تقرير طاعة الرضيع على ما أعتقد
ماذا تفعل الكنيسة دون علم
لقرون عاش ك
مؤسسة السيطرة ما يجب علينا
الحفاظ على السيطرة على الأغنام
ماذا يمكن أن يكون الرجل المسؤول
كامل ومع كل ما يجعل
حياة رجل مسؤول وهذا يعني
أيضا قدرته على الحب والمحبة
و
ولا تكون أداة
باريناس تجلب زوجتك مع قزم إلى
اشترى بلمونت من أرنود برنارد
قصر لم أشعر به
ما هو التعدي على شيء إلا
الشيء الذي أوصلني إلى عندما كنا
قبلة للمرة الأولى
النهاية هو أنا الذي تم تخميره
يرتدون ملابس سوداء ما في ذلك الوقت
يجب أن تكون كلها من الخشب مع طوق روماني
تحميل حتى ما شعرت به
Coupat ولكن ليس على الإطلاق مع الحقيقة
أنهم كهنة لم يعودوا حقيقة
يضر بصداقة قوية كانت لدينا
قال لنفسي أنكسر
شيء وهكذا لم يكن هناك شيء
لحقيقة أنهم كذلك
حياة الكهنة مع كاهن في
منزل لكنهم كانوا في طريقهم للاحتفال
كتلة ل
متأكد من أنني أعتقد أنه من المؤسف أننا
لا تسمح لهم بالمرور من خلال هذا
وجود عائلة لماذا هنا
والدليل أنه يفعلها ولا يفعل ذلك
لا تزعج الحياة الأسرية جي و
حياة الكنيسة
badalamenti مما أدى إلى كوستاريكا الحرادة
ماركو إنجلاند هيلين روبن تشينيو
قرأ الكرفس ألفانو عشرين باهاما هنا
في خمس نزهات قال الأبراشي نيكولاس
وقال رو والصين ستصل إلى أدنى مستوياتها
جيا نبيه بري كما سنعرف أين
بيتي بس والاحراج ورسسي ويب itf اللي
وضع دو ومعقل إيان بعض الدمقس
ومحظورة
أنها تنطوي على انحرافات محتملة
الانحرافات المحتملة ومع ذلك رأينا ذلك في
عدد الحالات في
الكنيسة
في الآونة الأخيرة أنا لا أتحدث عنه فقط
الاعتداء الجنسي على القصر ولكن الإساءات
الجنسية أيضا على الرائد لا
الموافقة على وجود انحراف عن
الجنس سيقول بعضكم نعم
ولكنه موجود في كل مكان في جميع
نعم المجتمع ولكن هناك المزيد
يمكننا حظره في نهاية الشهر فقط
نعيش بهدوء وصحة كلما زاد عددنا
يروج لهذا النوع من عدم الثقة
في الجينز وأنت تعلم أنني عادية
تصفية المغاربة تفعل وول ستريت
مصير المبلغ الاسمي أنيسة ثم
ثقافة السرية في الكنيسة
دائم فهو يحمي الإجراءات
ضار ويضع كل شيء في نفس الشيء
سلة serques على سبيل المثال لي في الوقت المحدد
حاضِر
أنا أكون
مقيد بشكل من أشكال السرية
تحت الأرض حتى تتمكن من الاستمرار
وزارة نحن قليلا في نفس
فئة من الكاهن الذي سيكون
ارتكب الاعتداء الجنسي على القصر
امزج كل شيء
مرحبا، كيف حالك
قال مرض السالمونيلا لولا له
كان لابد من فاتن ميناد بلقاني استراتيجية هذا
وهو أمر صعب ألا تكون قادرًا على ذلك
التواصل
حولي لن تكون قادرة على التواصل
ببساطة مع أبناء الرعية الآخرين
لا أقول ذلك لأنني
سأفعل شيئًا معاكسًا
الإنجيل ولا للبشرية البسطاء
ما هو صعب ليس نعم
أن تكون قليلاً من عدم المشاركة في
حقيقة
هناك هو جيد جدا
إنه لقاء مع الرب هكذا
هذه الأصوات هناك إنها جميلة جدًا
[موسيقى]
الذي ستعيشه اليوم تفعله
خطوة واحدة اقتربت
بالتواصل هذا المصطلح شركة هذه الكائنات
متحدين مع نسعى إلى أن نكون متحدين
مع بعضهم البعض في نفس هذا الحب
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
قاذفات حفيده ثيو بالانتشار
في ذهنك سواء كانت علامة هوندا أو
moa و sweden marie sy سبرينغز ذلك
متعب مدينتي جمدت ال btph والرباط
ذهب
كان الحل تحت الأرض
تكاد تكون تكريما للكنيسة
من الأسهل على السلطات
يمكن أن تستمر دون الكشف عن أي شيء لي
اختيار وأخيرًا خيار آخر مع أ
كانت اليونان دائمًا في الحقيقة
قد تكون أيضًا خدمة
يود أيضا رد الجميل إلى
الكنيسة تصبح ولكن ما هي
هل هناك خطأ ما
يخفي
viry milk fairebel يترك في alcan in
ثناء جميل لخلفنا في صور بيا
وينشأ الحكم بذلك
لإجبار كل شيء على عدم وجود ماء عسر
وقاتلنا بولوني وماثريكا يا
هنا أو هناك قال دومينيك وآن و
إنسيتا السود من أفريقيا إلى القادة
نجاح باهر armand وهاري حفر hayden elle
مشاهدة حالما ابن الثيران الشباب
هندي
الجنس لأنه ملف
المحرمات من الصعب التحقيق
البعض يتحدث عن 50٪ من الكهنة
سوف يمارس الآخرون
ما يقرب من 50٪ من غير الممارسين تمامًا
حالة من الواضح أن لديهم
عملي أكثر من ذلك مثل الضغط
من المثالي الكهنوتي يزن أكثر
بقوة عندما يكون الكهنة قليلين
كثير
هناك ما يزيد قليلاً عن 8000 كاهن في
خدمة الأبرشية اليوم
استمرت الأرقام في الانخفاض خلال
العقود الماضية وفي نهاية
شهر يونيو حوالي 120 رجلاً
سيدخل الكهنوت سواء
في حالة قيصر أو في إطار
لمجتمع ديني كان عليه
تقريبا نفس الرقم في العام
أخيرًا ولكن إذا كنت تريد ذلك
120 كجم بين 300 و 400
من مات من أجل العديد من الكهنة أنا
أعتقد أن الصعوبة في الواقع
يعيش الامتناع عن ممارسة الجنس يخلص
بالتدريج حسب النوع
الترتيب مع نفسه مع
القواعد لدينا رفيق لدينا
ماتي حيث لدينا ليلة واحدة
من وقت لآخر حان وقت العرض
لا ، إنه يجتاز تعليم الأساقفة
بحاجة إلى قروض من
يترك الكاهن يمرر
النشاط الجنسي المفرط والرؤية
اللحوم شيء جدا
متجذرة في الأسماء بالخارج
الكنيسة الكاثوليكية وداخليًا
الانتقام وممارسة الممارسين
تجد صعوبة في تخيل ذلك
يمكن للكهنة أن يمارسوا الجنس
أنت لست هناك
الأسرة لديها
مضاف
السيدة ماتاش مليمان في mli أو غيرها
وا ماتاريكا قاعة المدينة أمس رقبتي قوم
في سبع محطات توقف جنونية لطيفة
جزر سانت سولبيس تي هي المالية
أحذية رياضية صغيرة ولكن سوداء بارين مجمدة
نبيه بيري هذا
الذي يميزنا عن مكتبنا في
ليانا
من شأنه أن يقودنا إلى الجانب بشكل جيد ما يقول
اربعة حراس ولا صوت رجل
أن المسيحية فضيحة
ومن ثم وضع علاقة مباشرة
وعميق معه
مجرد تكهنات
من يفهمها
لقطة نجمك
النار ولا الطريق
إتيان إيفيرا سيطلب مني الجلوس في الخلف
أو إلى غرفتك في المملكة حيث تكون آمنة
في شهر ti ar baradoz
حتى سن العشرين لدي حياة هادئة
طبيعي لم يكن لدي رغبة في أن أكون
كاهن حتى لدي حياة جيدة
عادي سيرشح بقاء الكهنة
ليسوا كائنات فضائية كنت سأذهب إليها
قداس كل يوم أحد يريد بعض
إنشاء عائلة لديها وظيفة
في الواقع هذا عندما كنت
سيرجي لدراساتي الهندسية أنا
بدأ يحضر قسيس
طلاب الكنيسة الكاثوليكية و
على مدار عطلة نهاية الأسبوع كنت حقًا
تأثرت بنعمة الله بالحب
الله و لسبب غير مفهوم في
على أي حال كان لدي سبب بشري
الرغبة في أن يكون كاهنًا
باميان الأرجنتينية كنت ذاهبة إليه منذ زمن طويل
الأعمال المكتوبة بسرعة هي هايتي عليه
الوقت عندما بيا
كان من الطبيعي أنه كان من الواضح أنني
لا يمكن
قسم قلبي أو قطعه
اثنان هذا لا يمكن أن يكون لها حب
أفضلية لفتاة صغيرة
ثم بعد ذلك إلى الرغبة في تكريس نفسي
تماما لله و
إله
[موسيقى]
بفضل م
حقاً المدرسة اللاهوتية هي مدرسة حقيقية
الحرية مع مرشدنا
روحي
نحن أحرار في قول ما نريد
وإلى الحد الذي يصاحب ذلك
الروحية والمحافظة عليها في سرية مطلقة و
لذلك لا تخبر أحدا
أوه
[موسيقى]
نحن
إشعار للجميع ، إما أن نمرر السجلات
قال canistrelli سوء المعاملة على
باني ساي وان صوت الطبيعة
هبطت موخيتو سوناتا عشاق جان
ماري فيلون ميليت وفقدان الوعي
حسنا أنت وأنا أفعل
مليون بيا
[موسيقى]
أنت هنا في الندوة التي ندربها
المرشحين بوضوح في هذا
أبعاد العزوبة المكرسة نتبادلها
معهم حول هذا الموضوع ثم المزيد في
التبادلات الفردية إلى حد ما
تأكد من أنه حقًا
الاختيار الناضج ليس لمجرد نزوة
ولا لأنه كان لدينا
تجربة روحية قوية جدا
أننا سوف نخدم الرب بالضرورة
كمندرا عازب مكرسة ولكن
إنها تصنع حشدًا كثيفًا على السيارة
كانوت ولكن آلة 300 سرير تقتل
والمناطق التي يذهبون إليها بالفيديو
حيث تنهار مدح النيران و
شراء في الواقع لدينا تدخلات
اثنين من تدخلات علماء النفس
أيضًا من معالج جنسي يساعد أيضًا
هذه المنطقة من النشاط الجنسي إلى الأفضل
فهم كيف يعمل هذا
الجنس أن لديهم معنى و
انها جميلة انها لنا
أعطها الرب للإنسان و
المرأة لذلك ضع دائرة حول هذا الاختيار
العزوبة مبنية مع كل هؤلاء
عناصر أصدقاء جدد ألفي نوح 7pts
الاستيلاء على alcan i7 أو أي خطوة
يقدم بهذا المعنى والحنان
فتاة ميدلتون لم تخبر الغرفة قط
وكالة المخابرات المركزية كارنو
[موسيقى]
م
اجعلنا نعيش حسب بره فيه
الشكر للكثيرين
النعم من خلال يسوع المسيح لدينا
سيد
[موسيقى]
كان ينبغي أن تحتجزه بدع صبيح
في villemade يبقى خزانة بلدي ni abrashi
قال طريقة صامتة الملكة الكتاب المقدس
أليس
أنا شخصيا أنا بالتأكيد
مواتية لهذه العزوبة لأنه في
جمعية
مجتمع نرفضه في كثير من الأحيان
سؤال الله هل هذا من هذا القبيل
الرجال أيضا الراهبات الذين لديهم
نذر العزوبة والتخلي عن كل شيء
من أجل الله حسنًا ، أعتقد أنه أ
علامة مهمة تعطي علامة قوية
كما تريد أن تعطي نفسها بالكامل
هنا للتخلي عن كل شيء من أجل الله
قطع في الاجتماع استخدم جان otero
إتيان لاعب بداهة
السؤال بالنسبة لي هو أن أقول لنفسي
كيف سأبقى وفيا ل
الكلمة التي أعطيتها وهذا
تكريس حياتي كلها من
عندما أعرف ذلك في هذه العلاقة
حيا بيني وبين الله من خلال الصلاة
إذا كان هناك شك ولكن كل هذه الشكوك
يمكن رفعه بسهولة تامة
شقة أو يعود إلى هذه العلاقة
التي أحبها
مع يسوع المسيح الحي
أحيانًا يكون صحيحًا أن نعم يمكن أن يكون
الأسئلة التي يمكن للمرء أن يشعر بها
أو مثل هذا الشعور البارد في الحب ولكن
إنه موجود أيضًا أو نقوم بذلك مرة أخرى
خيار
za de molsheim في فيلق ديس المناجم
رفيق أدرار وبينه هذا كل شيء
النسيان والإطار أن هناك غضبك
إلى raucoules جلبت له الفيفا الرنة ذلك
ركوب الخيل في ليدو في كابورج التي تواجه الكاميرون
في حوض السباحة kadima و labeyrie في
الصين وهبة الأسد حسن البنا أ
قال واحد يسمى الهدوء أغسطس
[موسيقى]
لقد تعمدت في ذلك العمر
اعيش
مثل أي شخص آخر لدي صديقات
لذلك لم يكن لدي الآلاف أيضًا
لكن كان لدي صديقات من قبل
أراد أن يكون كاهن العروس والعريس
ربما سأذهب إلى آخر
كنيسة
الألمان
العام قبل العودة إلى
ندوة نقوم بها في كثير من الأحيان
التراجع مع الجيسوت
إنها 30 يومًا من صمت الصلاة
كل يوم نلتقي بمدير
روحي ووجدت نفسي ذات مساء
في غرفتي بجانب سريري
تبكي بفرح ولكن ليس بعد الآن
اغسل الماء بدموع الفرح لانه
أدركت ذلك بشكل معقول
كان الله دائما حاضرا في بلدي
الحياة وأنه أحبني بحب لانهائي
إجوانا خالية من العظم ولكن من المحتمل أن تكون
كارين م جزء من عجز زيت الغاز
كان على الأقل بعض ما يجعله زلقًا إلى حد ما
حالة n كانت الحمار الوحشي أو سمعت
نتحدث عن الفضائح
كان الكهنة عازب هو عليه
ليس هناك لا نعرفه لأنني موجود
واحد أنا أفضل
الرجال مثل أي شخص آخر هناك
لا تذهب المقدسة
فيلم النهضة عبدان أديل سال كارنو
حيث فعلت القضية ولا ذلك
مجلس الإدارة لتدريب
الكهنة لهم
يوضح أن ملف
أي شخص لديه ميل
لا يمكن قبول المثليين
يتدرب ككاهن في كنيسة
لا تدينوا المثليين
لا يزال الفرنسيون هم
هل أدينك لكنها هي
أدين الممارسة التي لا أعتقدها
الكنيسة اما ترفض للناس
مثليون جنسيا
نحن نحاول التأكد
أن مرشحينا هم أشخاص
هنا سلمي متوازن وافتراض
هذه الخدمة الكهنوتية بالكامل
طبل altri أم لا يجب أن نتوقف
ركوب الحافلة la rt l'ifo en
أكتوبر 2000 الفاتيكانا هي تنحني إليها
جميع التصميمات الداخلية زمرة الخريف
من الهيئات مثل جنون كيا حالة الخضار
à la rockhal الفاتيكان نيجي للإلكترونيات
لمس الذهب
كنت في lahti يوجين الألمانية إذا كانوا
أعترف بربط tenua cola و
مباراة تابيرنا التي انضم إليها
الاستقرار مثل المشكله سوف يكون لي
ثماني لكن هناك وجبة خفيفة
أجسام الغيرة لورا بلات
الحسن واتارا محلي لكن الاختراق
العسكرية نلاحظ اليوم أرض التكاثر
التجنيد للكهنوت هو أ
تجمع على أي حال
ضيق جدا هم من الرجال
أخيرًا تم إضفاء الطابع الاجتماعي عليهم من معظمهم
سن مبكرة في الكاثوليكية الذين لديهم
غالبًا ما كان في مدرسة خاصة
أولاد المذبح الذين تم الكشف عنهم وج
وهذا يعني جدا
يمارسون أخيرًا أنهم أنفسهم
أصبحت أقلية جدًا جدًا و
لذلك في هذا النوع من الأسرة للغاية
محافظ
عاشت الشذوذ الجنسي علانية في
ربما داخل شركة
الزوجين ليس أفق
ممكن
لشاب لم يجتذب
من خلال الزواج من جنسين مختلفين في عصره
فيذهب إلى الكهنوت
كندا تحت رحمة الموت في روما
مساعد روضة فابريس بونارد كارنو
tia i mua z
لم أشارك عائلتي أبدًا
هذه حياتنا الجنسية انتظرت الثلاثين
سنوات لأتمكن من التحدث عن هويتي
الجنس أولاً كان أسقفي الذي
كان مستمعًا طيبًا جدًا
على الرغم من أنه دعاني للتقاعد
في دير لمدة عام مع أ
دعوة لرؤيتهم ككاهن
مسؤول عن دعم الناس
الشاذ جنسيا كانت رغبتي الوحيدة
لأكون قادرًا على توحيد إيماني وهويتي
عميق
ما دام الوصول إلى المساء إيناف
عندما أخبره بأشياء ولكن
كان إغلاقًا تامًا و
ابس
شعرت بالعنف فيها
سلوك
أداما كين إلى ديدييه كل اللهب الأفضل
معروف من كورتيلس إلى فارو ليس كين
جعلها mottet التي ستقودها إلى هراء
ضابط الجمارك المشترك كين
لقد حكمت على التجربة من خلال جسدي وصحتي
عنف والدي تجاهنا
وهذا الظلم كان مثل
نوع من الاتصال لفتحه لـ
وصل البر بعد المسيح إلى الصديق
el fenomeno nina maninka net league and au
نادر الشاب manu الذي يجب أن يخفف
رحلة العقيد فال حتى إلى الرجيم و
طلاب giroud لأنه كان في
سنوات عندما عشت هذا قلت لنفسي
ولكن في يوم من الأيام أو سوف يعطيني الثنائي الآخر
القوة تعافينا من هذه العلامة أنا
أنا لمنع بالنعمة من
الرسامة التي سوف أنجح فيها
تجاوز من في داخلي إذا كان
ليست جيدة الموجهة للكهنوت ذلك
يبدو لي أنه الطريقة الوحيدة
ابحث عن مكاني
وأكد هو الرفاق الصين أنها
kanouted لبعض الألعاب يمكن أن أكون
تشعر بالقرب من أحدهما أو الآخر
ونشعر بأننا كنا نرتدي
نفس الهوية الجنسية لكنها كانت كذلك
المحرمات وعاشها الجميع داخليا
صحيح أن وقت الندوة
كانت أيضًا الأماكن المبحرة
يعلم أنه يمكننا التحدث مع بعضنا البعض نشعر به
نحن جيدا
عندما وجدت نفسي في هذا
جاذبية أو في العادة السرية
ببساطة عن طريق تخيل هذا أو ذاك
سوف أختبرها على أنها فاشلة
فيما يتعلق بهذا الالتزام الذي أنا
كان يستعد
الغني أو الديدييه حياة الكن ويات
في
من خلال تسليم الوزارة
اليوم هناك الكثير من الأعذار
انضممت واكتشفت ذلك إذا
شعرت بأنني قريب
أعذاره لأنني أنا
شعرت كأنني خبير
[موسيقى]
هناك مالو ديدير ، نعم سيوصلني إلى هناك
قائمة فرق اليوم في ساحات متكاملة
ستكون هناك حاجة للتنس في ويماوث
توماس
لذلك سوف يقرضه الماضي الأبيض
هذا ما يجعل حياته في الواقع إذا
كان هو الذي اختار أن يفعل ذلك بالفعل
أني أقبلها كما هي
لا يكون هذا الكاهن مستعدا
إنها وظيفة أنا رجل
قبل كل شيء لدي حياتي كزوجين
لدي أصدقائي أضحك أن الجميع
الأرواح
عليك أن تحتفل بزفاف لكنك تعلم
كيف يكون الشعور بالحب معًا
إنها الصعوبات التي أعرفها
المزايا التي أعرفها بمرور الوقت ماذا
قد يستغرق الأمر بعض الجهد
لقد جئت من قافية حضانة توأم حتى لو
يحظر أيضًا معرفة g10 إلى
نيكي هذه شائعة عائلتي
مدهش للغاية ولكن هنا سيأتي
ربما لم نختار أن نكون
مثلي الجنس هو موت لي
أعتقد أن القساوسة المثليين
ممارسين أم لا ، يمكننا أن نقول أن هناك
50٪ منها بلا شك الخطاب
المسؤول هو أن عادة
لا يمكن للمرشحين المثليين
أن تصبح كاهنًا يخلق من المحرمات المزدوجة
عن الناس
ربما مثلي الجنس و
ربما تمارس أيضا في
من المفارقات أن شروط الجنس أكثر
الكنيسة تطور الخطاب
رهاب المثلية عدوانية بعض الشيء مثلنا
شوهد منذ الثمانينيات كرد فعل على
حقيقة أن المجتمعات تطبيع
تدريجيا الشذوذ الجنسي
فكر أكثر في لحظة ندرة
الكنيسة تجذب الناس
مثليون جنسيا ولكن لديهم تماما
استوعبت حركة رهاب المثلية
موريناتي على ابواب دنيا عيسى
hayatou saoudien the cnam a rom morocco
في الكان كالاهاري أغسطس diageo أ
تم تصديقه
كيف أنا وباتريس مونجيو
الاسرة والعرائش الاهرام
باتريس ماس و لاتينا رسالة أ
زجاجة حتى أحضر القزم
اعتمد زعيم كندا رومانيا bnr في
نهاية سيئة في
تانوت ما يهم رقم هيمورو كارينا
والصباح الذي عقد في echery نعمان هذا هو
السجدة المتكئة هنا نصلي من أجله
المرشح لمنحه هنا هو
يجبر الشجاعة على المضي قدما
مهنة
التضحية بالنفس والتضحية بالنفس التواضع
هذا هو وضع الأيدي
الأسقف هو لفتة
انتقال هبة الله فيها
الكنيسة بالنسبة لي هي لفتة
رمزي يصنفني على أنه
لاعب مهم في الكنيسة
بدلا من أن يكون نوعا من
السوائل التي من شأنها أن تمر أو قوة
السحر الذي سينتقل إليّ حينها
أن هذه الفكرة هي بالضبط
أن والدي
عندما أصبح كاهنًا لهم و
خاصة لوالدتي
كدت يدي الله
فالات باتريس كريم الأتاسي IMF
الصناديق الأصلية اللاتينية مارك بيلمار في
جلسة ماراثون باولا في وايز في إت
ليتل ريد à la cani هذا الفن حيث آسا
بطة أو في موقع yahoo ariana الرسمي أو
لا يزال جيدا أبى bt
23 مايو 2003 لذلك نقوم بتحميل الصغير
الشاحنة التي استأجرناها مع بلدي
الأثاث الذي أخذني إليه
ينام الكتاب في الثانية صباحا
انتهينا من اتجاه المنشور
بحيث أودعت مائتي
الرسائل الموجهة للناس لـ
اشرح لهم قراري
الشرطة من الرجل الذي له جماهير
فيلم rams noaa schlink olga tanon no
بلد مثل محراثهم المنخفض للقراءة
هنا لذلك أقدر هذا كثيرا جدا
هذا العمل من المرشدين ، سواء
هنا الولادات والزيجات
أيضا حداد نادي الرباطي الوغد
مفاجأة في قاعة مراسي
ارتفاع متحف المتاحف حميد كنت قليلا
غريب على هذا أخيرًا كنت أ
كنت قليلا على الهامش
المتفرج هو المرافق ولكن في
مرات عديدة قلت لنفسي إنه
ليس من أجلك اخترت أن تعيش غيرك
شيء من كونه كاهنًا وبالتالي من أ
بطريقة ما تم إقصائي
كانت هناك متتاليات من الشعور بالوحدة
ثقيل جدا
هنا كنت أحاول العبور أيضًا
بشجاعة قدر الإمكان ثم هناك
كان لديها ccds من التسلسلات هناك
لديها الكثير وهذا ما
يسمح لعقد أعتقد كل شيء
كانت نشطة للغاية لأنني كنت
دائمًا ما أفعله
أشرك نفسي بشكل كبير في ما
ما فعلته لأني أؤمن به
على أي حال وأنا أفتقده والجانب
علائقية
حنون جسدية هذا النوع من هوى
من الرفقة اليومية
عاطفة حنان حنان
تبادل خاص مع شخص
قد يسمى الحب مريض
أخيرا أعتقد
[موسيقى]
قد نقول أن الله محبة لدينا
جميل أن نقول إننا نبذل حياتنا من أجل الحب
بالنسبة لي كان من الواضح أنه لم يكن كذلك
لا يكفي أن يكون هناك ملف
سمة من سمات الحب الذي أفعله
لا يمكن أن يعيش من كان
التعبير عن نفسي مع كل ما عندي
أن تكون شاملاً عاطفياً و
الجنسية هنا لم تكن موجودة وذاك
لقد عانيت من بطارية سليمان الثانية
حدادي يجعل المراوح لعبة جيدة
صالح فوزان صفقة هواوي علي
شك شومان في ما إذا كان قد عقد بي
عسل كيت عايد ايل الجديدة سيلفي لا
أنا مريض بينما الكومة
على عجلة القيادة من القمصان الآسيوية
جديد أو استخدام الجوائز allybar
السكان المحليين السعر كان المسرح
سوء فهم بعض أعضاء
عائلتي هي أساسًا لهم
يبدو أنه ليس فقط مجنون ولكن
علاوة على ذلك يبدو لهم أنه
خيانة بينما كنت أ
إنجاز من نفسي ومن بلدي
مشروع لذلك كنا في تشويه
المجموع معهم ولذا اضطررت إلى ذلك
ابتعد
أفراد عائلتي المقربين جدا
حتى لا نعاني من هذا
يامالو باتريس اليوم مودي الأمريكي
موسى ليكون رائع رفع thillois
صحيح أنه في التقليد
نحن كاثوليك رأي كاهن حتى
عندما تركنا الوزارة نحن
لا يزال قريبًا لذلك ما زلت أمتلك
الانطباع بأنني كنت كذلك للآخرين
مع كاهن وهكذا نعم هو لي
الذنب
الشعور بالخجل قليلاً في الواقع
أولئك الذين لديهم القيم التي تم نقلها إلى كيم
تدرس من قبل والدي والدي
عائلة
أنا في البحث عن عالم اليوم
فكريا فلسفيا
لا أعرف حتى ما إذا كان الأمر كذلك
هذا يعني أن الله موجود فلا أعلم
ليس أنا
ولا يهم في النهاية أعتقد ذلك
أجمل شهادة نستطيع
رد الجميل هو العيش كأخوة
مع آمين الآخر
مارتينز وأميان بطيئا في مستوى التوقعات أ
مفتوح في الوقت المناسب لم يكن أبدًا شيئًا أنت
وضح النهار أين الآن
نتوقع السيدات ونظرية غانا
عمد اي تيونز في أييت ومعظم أهوجا
إنها الأجواء داخل الإنكار
أما الأسطوري كانيزا واكوال
مايكل ماتيس وريا الجبل
انتصار تونغ يانغ جيا عندما نغادر
يشترى
صباح الخير مع رفيقك
الوضع هو نفسه دائما
الطريق الى
[موسيقى]
فوز
ستجعلنا نقول أين نذهب بكفالة دان
صوفي أمريكي من الماشية
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
سجل مارتن نايت فينك
تاكسيفوليا
أتالايا تودوروف العسكرية من يفعل ذلك
caennais cia
لذلك التقينا بالخارج
الكنيسة مع الأصدقاء المشتركين الذين أعرفهم
ليس لأنه كان كاهنًا كان خلال
عطلة نهاية الأسبوع لذلك عندما اكتشفت أنه
كان كاهنا
في سحر تعمل وكان
من الصعب بالنسبة لي أن أستدير
مانهاتن لايوري يجب أن يفعلوا القاهرة
لم يهرب من أفريقيا المادي
لم أتخيل نفسي في هذا الوقت
بقدر ما حصل لهم كل هذا
يولد مثل الحرمان
الإحباط مثل الألم لا نستطيع
مشاركة وجبة عائلية معًا
يمكن أن تذهب في إجازة ولكن عليك
دائما تكون رصينة دائما كذب و
في نفس الوقت والقتال جميل جدا
لحظات وذلك عندما نكون هذا كل شيء
معسكرين في جدوله لديه
لا شيء أكثر لفعل العجلة الخامسة من
مدرب ماذا
يجبرنا على الذهاب إلى الرنة إذا كان هذا نحن
هل هذا أديل وباردي مال باب
[موسيقى]
في أعين الآخرين أنا متصورة
عازب أبدي ليس لديه
لا أحد في حياته لديه ذلك على أي حال
أقابل أطفالي مرتين هناك
تم تقديمه كصديق لأولادي
شك في أي شيء ليس من السهل أنا
أود أن أشارك هذا مع بلدي
الأطفال إلى جانبه لا يوجد أحد
يعرف ذلك من عائلته من أصدقائه
حقا يجعلك تعتقد أنني لست كذلك
أن ما تتحرك مثل عشيقة
ألعاب ماري جاتي فتات وضح النهار أو
هل الفرنسية عادية عندك
وعد يا مكان نعرفه عندما نفعل
فقط الأسلحة في متناول اليد جاهزة للتصوير
القانون الدولي وأوروبا
أنا غاضب لأنه
حقا الرجل الذي يناسبني قبل
الزواج لكل الطلاق انهاء
لقد طور المجتمع ما يمكن أن يكون
تغيير ذلك المتدينين من الرجال والنساء
وشخص في حياتهم الكنيسة الذين
حسن النية لكل ما لا يهتم
من المعاناة التي نعيشها أكثر من اللازم
من السهل ألا يكون الأساقفة ممتلئين
السلطات والكنيسة سلطات كاملة
نريد فقط أن نعيش مثل أي شخص آخر
عالم
ثم يظهرون لكبار السن bouissou
que friborg كل الموسيقى الليلية وواحد
الهاتف أنا غني أو أموت لم أقل أي شيء
أن يكون هذا التحصين رينزا إشعار للجميع
ألقاب منها معمر الكذادي لواكي
مرات مساعدة برمائية أعتقد إذا كان ذلك
يقودهم ليعيشوا حياة مزدوجة
من الضروري أنهم ليسوا كذلك
مستعدون أو يتخلون عن الكهنوت
أعتقد أن المعمد لا يرغب
ليس كاهنا
منافق أعتقد أنه من الأفضل ألا
لا تمرين لأهل الله أ
مثل هذه المهمة حتى أنا عندما
حتى
صدمت لأنها لا تعرف ذلك
كيف اقول وانها ليست صادقة
لذلك أعتقد تجاه هؤلاء النساء
إنه ليس جيدًا ومن ثم مقابل دي
مجتمعهم لا أرى كيف
يمكن تحديد موقعه
ينظر إليهم في أعينهم
[موسيقى]
بالمناسبة ، ساعدنا المسيحي على التويهري
عندما عربةتي jaouen minel
أسعار الأعمال أو أسعار الهالي اليوم اليونانية
ذهول وهو أمر غير متوقع تمامًا
الشباب ويب الشيطان الأحمر أو bolton أو
الدراجة الجبلية أو الدراجة النارية دون الأخرى قلت لنفسي
أنني أرغب في تكوين عائلتي الخاصة
وقد تكون عائلة سعيدة
مناخ
uncc
كريستيانا ترست أكتوبر في الحديقة
موكب جميل سيجلب ون جياباو لأحد
مهمة داماس مرهقة وجوقة كارين
اهتمامات فابيو بيريل في مسرح رامساو
البرني هو منجم الحسناء السونوتوني
من استريا يمكن أنا أو من أنيسيت برايتون
حبل وخمسة مصمم من المنطقة
Sabrina إلى Mananjary قلت إنه quine
هرب الطريق أو mongie بايرون جدا
بسرعة في البداية قال لي إذا لم أكن كذلك
جاهز سيكون لدينا أطفالنا
يعاني كثيرا لكنه لم يكن كذلك
قضية إنجاب أطفال يعيشون معهم
وزن هذه السرية
كل بني الكهنة يعانون
هذا اكيد
[موسيقى]
أوه
سوف تعطي ليا في أي حال كان علينا أن نموت
نتوقع أن يجلب البارونا كيناز إلى
حجم فيات قام بالمهمة التي كان لديك
الكثير من فرك الكتفين مع شعب المايا من القصور الذاتي هناك
عندما آتي إلى الكنيسة
إنه أكثر لأنه هادئ أحبه
انظر النوافذ الزجاجية المعشق للقلق
جمالية ولكن الدين بالنسبة لي
لا تقلقني على الإطلاق لا ينبغي أن يكون
ولكن بالنسبة لي هو المكان قليلاً
عمل والدي لذلك أنا ذاهب
لأنه قليلا هو من هناك
الذين يعيشون هنا وفي نفس الوقت
الدين يفعل ذلك بشكل سيء لدينا
عانى كثيرا من الاضطهاد
الأهوال وكل ما يرعبني
[موسيقى]
تايشو فتاة تقطع وتبتسم
منحنيات جميلة وفي العالم تؤلم
لعبت شاركت
جزر الكناري
[موسيقى]
لذا فهذه هي الحقيبة حيث توجد
جمعت معظم الأشياء
لم يتبق لديه الكثير من الأشياء
لكن مازال
هذه صور حيث يمكنك رؤيتها
لابد أن لديه 25 عامًا
30 سنة التي يجب أن تكون في السنوات
60 هي الصورتان الوحيدتان له
التي أملكها من هذه الفترة لم يكن أبدًا
أراد كثيرًا التحدث معي حول هذا الأمر والدي حول هذا الموضوع
الفترة القديمة و ص عندما كانت
كاهن لأنه كان مؤلمًا جدًا
له
هدفهم في ليون
تواجه الطريق لكنها رياضة
من كرام ساتارا شرمان أو
القمامة أو في هيوستن المسرات
وجبة
التقى والداي في
كلية في منطقة ليون وبلدي
علم الأب الفلسفة وهو
قابلت أمي التي كانت صغيرة
مقاولي الرسالة وسقطوا
في حالة حب وقرر والدي المغادرة
أوامر الزواج
falvai الأقبية القوية التي تميز
مرة
أن لديه عائلة كبيرة والدي
كان لديه أربعة إخوة وهكذا هناك
كان هناك الكثير من الناس أمام هذا
بما في ذلك أبناء عمومته كل هؤلاء
الناس الذين لا أعرف من يجفف
الصور ولكني لا اعرفهم لديهم
رفض والدي عندما أصبح لا
الكهنة الذين تزوجوا وكانوا
أطفال لأننا أطفال
فرنسا في الوقت المحدد كيف نعيش نحن
7 سنوات من العمر لا ينبغي أن يكون لدينا
ولد
[موسيقى]
وكان والدا والدتي غاضبين
كانوا مهاجرين إسبان
منهم
الدين مقدس وهكذا هو
عندما علموا أن والدتي كانت
وقعوا في حب راهب لهم
كانت الدراما التي أطلقوا البادا أخيرًا
في النهاية أكدت الغارة القليل من المساعدة
جان لويس فاراخان هذا هو المنشور الوحيد
التي وجدها في بريتاني
في قرية صغيرة
صغير جدًا صغير جدًا والناس لديهم
استكشف هذا
أن لديه ماضًا كهذا
ديني وجد وظيفة مدرس
الفلسفة في مدرسة كاثوليكية
وقد بدأ الجحيم وحصلنا عليه
بدأ اضطهاده شريرًا
ذلك مع حزمة الرسائل المهينة
مع القرف فيه
تهديدات بالقتل على الجدران
كانت الجدران وأبرز ما في العرض
بداية إشعال النيران
الذين اضطهدونا هم الوالدان
من تلاميذ المدرسة الكاثوليكية لذلك
كلهم مؤمنون
أطلقوا على أنفسهم المتدينين السابقين
من يعلمنا الفلسفة
الأطفال سوف يفسدهم
تفكيك يا للأسف أبدا سباق القوارب
أطفال الصمت بعد ساعات من الصورة مولودية
القصب والمعادن الصلبة هو قوس
المروحة oualidia
نرى ما قيل لي أنه كان كافياً
فظيع قيل لي أناس مثلك
أبي نقوم بتطهير الملف ما والدي
لا يزال يعيش 20 عامًا بصفته أ
ديني حتى في عشرين عاما لا يوجد
خمس صفحات من الملفات لا ينبغي أن تكون
يسخر من العالم
لذلك إذا كان في خمس صفحات فذلك بسبب ذلك
تم شرحه بالفعل yutaka doan
haruna cas à châtelet يصور بحر إيجه
يؤدي في olala إلى الروح بأربع سنوات
البلقاني هو كل التيجان
جرائم عنف ولكن الفن أواه
البطاطا الساخنة خلف و homo roffit
الدولة الكحولية على شبكة الإنترنت تلتقي ب
وقال مجلس إيقاع الخطوط الجوية المحلية
لذلك رأيت البعض في أبرشيتنا من
على نحو فعال
كان لديها زوجة تتوقع طفلًا
هل هو هناك أقول حسنًا عليك أن تفعل
أوقف وزارتك التي تعتني بها
من زوجتك وطفلك وهذا خير
ل
للطفل يجب أن تكون له الأسبقية على كل شيء
بلل أصدقائك تتدلى
ساتاروف سيذهب إلى الشرق الجميل
عرضت عن طريق شراء marini made in
كان أين إيريك أبيدال وباتريس إيفرا أين
انها العبث
لم تقل سيلفيان عيساتو شيئًا أبدًا
ضابط على اليمين ابتلع الفريق في
أنت وكل ما حدث
مع قصص الاعتداء الجنسي على الأطفال
الكهنة الذين أساءوا إلى الأطفال
كان هناك الكثير من العمل الذي تم
بواسطة وسائل الإعلام من قبل لجنة
التي تم وضعها بشكل جيد ومن
هناك بدأنا العمل معهم
إذن هذه هي الملاحظة إلى الأساقفة
من هو رئيس رئيسي في الاستقبال
مرافقة اولاد الكهنة
والتشجيع الديني للوصول إلى
أرشيفات الأبرشيات والجماعات
راهبات
بعد كل أسقف يكون حرا أم لا
للعمل في روح المرء وضميره هو
أول مرة نسمعها في فرنسا
أخيرا كلمتنا
وزوج نعومي واتس بمعدل في
النهائي فقط في لطيفة لجميع الحماقات
أن المجوهرات أمس ستخبر أين helaba
لسنوات كان لا يزال
طلب البقاء في
الرعايا وفي خدمتهم و
للتخلي عن زوجاتهم وأهلهم
الأطفال وهذا لا يليق بكنيسة
كاثوليكي
أي مهمة سهلة عبر
نانو
باربارينا يعود
في الحياة
ربما رسالة اكتشفتها
بعد وفاة والدتي ولدت من ولدت
كتبه والدي يمكننا القول
رسالة حب تجعله والدي
قلت لأمي في ذلك الوقت هو
حتى اسمي الأول مكتوب و
هذا ما يقوله لرؤية هذه الفتاة الصغيرة
ابنة ابنة أخذها والدها
من قبل والدته التي كانت لديها عيون فقط
اعتقدت أنه يمكنك أن تتخيل
أن تحبنا جاء إلى الذهن أ
الانعكاس الذي صنعته لي
يود الحصول على القليل من سيلفيان
عيون سوداء نعم سيكون لديك عينيك
السود وهذا الوجه الصغير هانز فان
[ __ ] سيكون طفلنا إذا كنت
تريد هدية جميلة تأتي إلي من
بعد ذلك
منذ الآن كلا والدي
تركوا لهذا اليوم وفي كيبيك يتعاملون معها
جيني بين مازل المؤمنين لاكي
المروة بسعر في البلياردو أو العيش في
هو قمر بوهلال ثابت
تريد android و iphone
صلابة كلب الدرواس mylène التي هي في بعض الأحيان
ضرورية لتكون قادرة على الحكم ولكن
من ناحية أخرى ، لها عيوب الوجود
لقد تغير ببطء شديد ونرى كيف
الأب فرانسوا يمر كما هو
يمكن أن تغير بعض الأشياء
وعليه أن يقنعه بضرورة ذلك
تمكن من إزالتها
عادات الفرامل جيدة كل شيء
المؤسسات الكبرى وحول العالم
صعب السؤال
أنا مسيحي كاثوليكي
ممارس المهنة
هنا و
إذا بقيت في هذه الكنيسة
كاثوليكية كان بإمكاني أن أترك 25 مرة
لأنها من الداخل
يمكننا أن نجعل الأشياء تحدث
ليس بالمغادرة بإغلاق الباب و
كعميل أو في غضون عشر سنوات
هذا هو موقعي هذا هو موقفي
الشخصية كمسيحي في
على أي حال من شمعة الهاوية في مهب الريح
وشاب أوكانا كامارو هو بالتأكيد لا
ابن اليوم هذا في اللطف مثل هذا
يجب على من شاهد تشارلز الذي عبر
أوقد لربط الأذكياء
هاميلتون الأرض مثل IMF صدمة يفعل
التنس لدرجة أنها تزاحمها
كانت وسائل إعلام لبنانية قبيحة
اصعد أيضًا إلى المهمة التمهيدية
لي عند الفجر وتناول آن الأبيض
alimatou طريق واريس حيث الشباب
موهبة مثل اللوفر في كل مكان أحمر
مبادرة الابن التي كانت لطيفة
أصدقاء وافي الكاثوليكيين تصنع أ
آلة مسائية أوتاوا العلامة التجارية
sheraton les manceaux ولكن هنا في
هل سيصدر مدينتي ليون لو فافنتيا
ouattara n إلى rouhia gibeau سيكون لديه
المسؤول عن هوايتهم gatti ville kanoute
السبب الرئيسي في أن الجميع
يرى العالم حقيقة أن الكهنة يعانون
وقد حان الوقت لفتح هذا
إمكانية لمن يرغب
الثاني الذي يبدو لي غير متأكد من ذلك
ناجح هذا ما
من شأنه أن يزيد من عدد الدعوات
والثالث هو ذلك
الكنيسة الكاثوليكية عاجزة
أن يكون لديك كلمة معقولة على
الجنس إذا كان لديه كهنة
متزوج سيكون لديهم الحق
[تصفيق]
في عام 2021 كنت سأقول الموقف
أكده البابا أننا
لن يعود إلى مسألة
العزوبة الكنسية
إنه موقف يوجد عليه
لن يكون لها تطور في السنوات إلى
تأتي على وجه التحديد لأنها ليست كذلك
وظيفة تأديبية فقط
إنه أيضًا شيء
لتنطلق من صوفية من الدينية
شيء متجذر في
عزوبة المسيح كما هي
المؤسسة التي ليست مجرد
مؤسسة بشرية مثل المدرسة أو
مثل الأمم المتحدة فهو لا يعرف ما هو عليه
المؤسسة التي هي انبثاق
الله أولا لذلك لا تفعل
أنها أكثر من اللازم
يتعرفون على بعضهم البعض أيضًا
تاريخيا هذا هو السبب
أن استراتيجية النسر وهي كذلك
دائما يمكن للمرء أن يقول نوعا ما
تحديد هذه الخيارات وبالتالي
نظام العزوبة الذي ليس كذلك
هذا الانضباط بالفعل
مؤرخة تاريخيا حتى من يستطيع
تكون الأطراف سنجد أكوام منها
المبرر الروحي لفعل ذلك
كما لو أنها أتت مباشرة من عند الله
الإصلاح العميق الأول الذي سيكون
ملتزم بالكنيسة سينتج عنه
سلسلة من الإصلاحات الأخرى و
إنه تأثير دومينو مجنون للغاية
لمؤسسة أن ترى أن كل شيء
فجأة يتحرك جزء من الهيكل
لكن الثاني سينتقل الثالث
أيضا وأن الهيكل كله و
تغيير هذا شيء جدا
محزن وأننا لا نأخذ هذا
القرار بسهولة وأعتقد ذلك
لن يأخذها فرانسوا
سوف تسعى أمالفيناتو للدفاع عن الصديق
فيل كامبل آلان يستيقظ في إيطاليا
من روماني جري توماس الحلقة
حفلة رياضية
[موسيقى]
بغداد
قال ماريزا سائق الخروبي الترابي
سوف ينتهي بعض arnout أو wemmel
لم تكن وحدها متأكدة من أنها كذلك
أيضا الحاخام الياهو
dati الذي يربطها بـ ty dennis ruy ya
ما الذي تغير
هو أن تكون قادرًا على عيش حياة عادية
الأسرة هنا قبل ظهر الأحد نحن
يخرج من القداس يخرج الكاهن من
قداس يقابله معظم الوقت
إنه وحيد في الجيش ، حسنًا
هناك أتيت يوم الأحد مع عائلة أكثر
الأكثر اعتيادية مع الأصدقاء وأنا
أعتقد أن هذا ما تغير أكثر
ابن يوم هو الأول للرومانيين
سيقود المدعى عليه في صالة الألعاب الرياضية إلى الإقلاع
الروماني بادا تاليكا التي نعومي فان
حصلت على مكاني خالٍ من الناس
ضار لأنني أعلم أنه
ليس بالأمر السهل لأنه سيضطر إلى ذلك
اتخاذ قرارات بالضرورة لأن
الكنيسة لن تتغير في خمسة
دقيقة بالتأكيد ليس في ستة أشهر و
هذا هو الوضع إلى حد كبير
هي دائما تثير مخاوف
لأننا نقول لأنفسنا أنه سيكون هناك
العقبات في طريقهم وهذا هو
لأننا نريد لآرائنا
السعادة التي رأيناها وأننا
رأى الشعور أنه يعطي الثقة
ماذا نقول
لديك إخوان إنه قديم
مؤسسة ميلان لديها قواعدها
ولكن ما هو أمام
قصة حب
فيليون ميتاليكا
سيكون هناك
نجمة
ل
العلامة التجارية مورتون أو هاواي ليس لها حشد
أوزة الحيوان شرف جيرار أتنكو دوريا
مؤخرا الصيف mokulu حالمة rototo
مقاعد انجريد أو اليكس
السنة المسرحية المقررة كاميمورا
إذا كان القانون يفعل ويذهب عهده
أديلين الخميس ما زلنا باق
[موسيقى]